- [Voiceover] "Which x-values
make the ordered pair
"X, comma negative
seven, a solution of the
"following inequality?"
The inequality is two X minus seven Y is
less than 25.
And so they give us some
choices, and I encourage you
to pause the video and see
if you can figure it out
on your own.
All right, now let's
work through it together.
They're constraining that
Y is going to be equal to
negative seven.
And so if we make that
constraint, we can replace
this Y with a negative seven.
So we can rewrite the
inequality as two X minus seven
times negative seven, since
we're constraining Y to be
negative seven, is less than 25.
And so this is going to be
two X minus negative 49,
or two X plus 49, is less than 25.
Now if I just wanna
isolate the X on one side,
which we see for these
inequalities up here,
so we could subtract 49 from both sides.
So subtracting 49 from both sides, we get
two X is less than, let's see, 49 minus 25
would be positive 24, so this would be
negative 24.
Now to isolate the X, we
just divide both sides by two
and we're not gonna change
the inequality, since we
are multiplying or dividing
by a positive value.
Positive two.
So this is going to be X
is less than negative 12.
And lucky for us, this is a choice.
So as long as, if Y is
equal to negative seven,
as long as X is less
than negative 12, we will
satisfy this inequality.
Let's do another one of these.
And this one is a little bit more visual.
So "Which Y-values make the ordered pair,"
so in the last one we
constrained what Y was,
and we figured out what X values would
satisfy this inequality.
Now we're going the other way around.
We're constraining X and we're saying,
what Y values would make
the ordered pair true?
Or make it a solution?
"Which Y values make the
ordered pair 5 comma Y
"a solution of the
inequality represented by the
graph below?"
So they didn't give it to us
algebraically, they gave it
to us visually.
And so to be a solution,
that means we have to be
in this blue area.
So this pair, so negative five,
comma six.
That would be a solution to
the inequality being depicted.
Something that sits exactly
on the line, this would
not be a solution, because
notice the line, as you can see
this lower boundary
line, is a dashed line.
If it was filled in, than
anything on the line would be
a solution.
But since it's dashed, things on the line
aren't solutions.
It's only things that are
above the line are going to
be solutions.
So let's see what they're
asking us to think about.
So they're saying, they're
constraining X to be
equal to five.
So X equals five is everything,
let me see if I can draw this.
X equals five is everything on
that line right over there.
Now, if we assume that X equals five,
we're gonna be someplace on this line,
how do we have to constrain Y to make sure
that we are in the solution?
Well, we have to constrain Y so
that we are above the line, for
X equaling five, just to be clear.
So we have to be above,
our possible points are gonna be the ones
once again, we're
constraining X equals five,
the possible points are the ones,
that I'm showing in magenta.
And actually I could
keep going if I want to.
So Y is going to have to be greater than,
it can't be greater
than or equal to seven,
it has to be greater than seven.
If it was greater than or equal to seven,
we'd be including the point on the line,
but I already talked about
this being a dashed line
so we don't want to include
the points on the line.
We only want to include
the points above the line.
So Y is going to be greater than seven
which is this choice right over there.
If X is equal to five, as long as Y is
greater than seven, we are going to be
in the solution set.